[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com it looks like yet another
piece of that infamous Christopher
Steele Trump Russia dossier the one that
the trumpets have been sort of going
apoplectic to try to debunk for months
now another element of it seems to have
been proven true or at least
corroborated and you might remember you
might not that one of the assertions of
the steel dossier was about the
involvement of Blackwater founder Eric
Prince in trying to set up a
back-channel between the Russian Kremlin
and then president-elect Trump it was in
January of 2017 before the inauguration
of Trump that supposedly Eric Prince was
trying to set up this back-channel and
as a quick reminder Blackwater is the
mercenary firm often hired by the US
government
Eric Prince is its founder he also
happens to be the brother of Secretary
of Education Betsy DeVos which is a
story for a different day if that's new
information to you and after the dossier
surfaced alleging that prince tried to
set up this back-channel prince denied
it
his attorney denied it and we now have a
new report months and months later which
says that Robert Muller might already
have evidence that indeed Eric Prince
did exactly this tried to establish this
back channel between the Trump
transition team and Kremlin operatives
and the Washington Post has a great
story on it where they report that a
witness who is cooperating with Robert
mullahs investigators says yeah the
meeting took place and the meeting took
place in January of 2017 and what Eric
prince told congressional investigators
he didn't deny that the referenced
meeting happened he denied that it was
planned saying instead oh it was a
totally chance
encounter and also denied that it had
anything to do with US Russia relations
visa vie the inauguration of President
Donald Trump but that happens to be the
exact opposite of what this cooperating
witness has told Robert Muller according
to the Washington Post report and
according to the witness the meeting was
not a chance encounter it was set up in
advance and it was specifically set up
so that a representative of Trump's
transition team would meet a delegate
from Russia specifically to figure out
how to communicate in the future and
we're now getting beyond sort of
circumstantial inaccuracies or something
you could write off to a semantic
disagreement right there's no way that
we can say semantics explains the
difference between Eric Prince's version
of events and this cooperating witnesses
version of events you can't say the
language was ambiguous there are
somebody is flat-out lying here if these
are the assertions that have been made
by each party either it was a planned
meeting or it was a chance encounter
that Eric prince absolutely did not
expect if it's a planned meeting then
Eric prince directly lied to
investigators and that's something that
usually ends up with you having a pretty
bad time and this also sort of more
broadly shows the consistent pattern by
Trump associates to try to create back
channels right because it's not just
Eric Prince from Blackwater accused of
trying to create a back channel to
Russia you might remember that the exact
same accusation exists against Donald
Trump's son-in-law Jared Kushner the
accusation that he met with Russian
ambassador Sergey kis lyac to do almost
this exact same thing potentially on a
sort of more ongoing basis than just for
the transition period Kushner was
looking at doing this at creating this
back-channel to the Kremlin specifically
to get around American intelligence
agencies awareness of what it is that
they're doing and as I read about this
there's no way that Moeller's team is
just feeling around right I mean they
clearly know what is going on and are
trying to see who's lying about this at
this point last week we kind of talked
about it and I pointed out
and it's not something that I came up
with uniquely right I mean it's widely
known that when investigators at this
level the the investigators working at
the level of Robert Muller when they
asked questions they asked questions
typically that they already know the
answers to to try to figure out who is
lying and where there are disagreements
or inconsistencies but they must know in
this case what the truth is and I would
love to see Eric prints taken down
reportedly a multi-billionaire just like
his sister Betsy DeVos who has made just
disgusting amounts of money basically
selling private war services to
governments including the government of
the United States and if you're
wondering what's going on with
Blackwater these days I haven't heard
much about it that's because they've
changed their name
Blackwater technically no longer exists
it was first called Blackwater it was
then renamed Z services like X E even
more innocuous and then later renamed
Academy with an AI most companies don't
want to be regularly changing names
because you sort of build brand
awareness and recognition under one
particular name this is the opposite a
cat when you hear the name Academy with
an AI you say
Blackwater and mercenary services and
private war contracting that doesn't
sound at all like a company that would
be doing that that's exactly what they
want and indeed Blackwater as black
water doesn't even exist anymore yeah
that's a problem and also we know that
patronage and nepotism is rampant yeah
this White House do you think this
connection led to Betsy DeVos becoming
the education secretary that's been the
speculation for a while I mean she her
husband and her I mean she has got a ton
of money as well I don't want to make it
seem like it's the guy who wears a
million dollar they both between them
were donating the max2
Trump and cronies and whatever so yeah I
mean certainly I would speculate that
the Eric prince connection is a
connection that was relevant for her but
also she and her husband were donating
big bucks to Trump so I think there's no
question that she had no business being
Secretary of Education there's no doubt
about that
how she got into the position could have
been Eric Prince could have been because
of her donations who knows at this point
but yet another piece of the steel
see a reportedly corroborated this is a
big story that happened over the last I
guess we would say 12 took 12 to 14
hours you probably know if you watch our
show that for weeks and weeks and weeks
the White House has been super careful
not to admit that Donald Trump was in
any way involved or even knew about the
hundred and thirty thousand dollars in
hush money that was paid and the
non-disclosure agreement that was put in
place for pornstar stormy Daniels who
had an affair with Donald Trump I think
at this point we can say with basic
basically total certitude that the
affair took place it's a question of how
much Trump was involved in the cover-up
and the framing all along from the Trump
side has been first of all it's all made
up now if you don't believe that it's
all made up and increasingly people
don't the argument is the payment was
made personally by Trump's personal
attorney Michael Cohen the
non-disclosure agreement doesn't even
have Trump's signature on it which we
talked about yesterday is probably a way
to try to maintain plausible deniability
about the entire thing but the strategy
all along has been never acknowledged
that anything took place and certainly
don't acknowledge that Trump had any
knowledge of or involvement in any deal
making whatsoever with stormy Daniels
regardless of whether you believe that
the affair did or didn't take place it
all blew up in Trump's face yesterday
and he is now reportedly furious with
his press secretary Sarah Huckabee
Sanders because she seemed to
accidentally admit at least it appeared
to be an accident that Donald Trump was
involved in arbitration with stormy
Daniels and presumably knew about that
hush money payment and the
non-disclosure agreement in in this
apparent desperation to show that Trump
came out on top
Sarah Huckabee Sanders said we won this
in arbitration and of course any normal
person would say well if you're
admitting that there's something to win
it sorry if you're admitting that you
won something you're admitting that
there was something to win which has not
been directly acknowledged until
yesterday take a look at this first clip
breasts
our feelings on that situation in
regards to the stormy Daniels payments
but specifically can I ask did the
president approve of the payment that
was made in October of 2016 by his
longtime lawyer and advisor Michael
Cohen look the president has addressed
these directly and made very well clear
that none of these allegations are true
this case has already been won in
arbitration and anything beyond that I
would refer you to the president's
outcome outside counsel when did the
president address specifically the cash
payment it was made in October of 2016
has denied the allegations against him
and again this case has already been won
and arbitration anything beyond that I
would refer you to outside counsel about
that at this time though I've addressed
this as far as I can go yeah so listen
number one Jeff Zeleny is right that
Trump hasn't addressed this directly but
let's ignore that for now because twice
there Sarah Huckabee Sanders says we
Trump won this in arbitration and there
was follow-up because it didn't get by
the reporters in the room who realized
if something has been won then who won
it and when and in this next clip I
apologize because the sound on the
source clip glitches but I think we'll
still be able to figure out sort of the
gist of what sarah huckabee Sanders is
saying here you said that there's
arbitration that's already been won by
by the president's personal attorneys
and for details on that I would refer
you to them you're aware of them so what
can you more can you hear with us I can
share that counsel on any details beyond
that yellow that second part is huge
right Sarah Huckabee Sanders is the
White House press secretary she doesn't
report about issues that relate only to
Trump's attorney Michael Cohen right in
fact she's super careful basically to
never explain anything to say anything
that doesn't relate directly to Donald
Trump she just says listen I'm the White
House press secretary and I can't speak
about that because it relates to this
person or that person who don't work in
this administration the fact that she
says something means that it relates to
Donald Trump and that Trump won
something in our
betrayin now it's not true that Trump
want anything in arbitration by the way
but that doesn't matter because the big
thing here is if she even says that
there was something for Trump to win
it's because there is some agreement and
totally predictably Trump is furious
Trump is furious with Sarah Huckabee
Sanders she had been doing so well I
guess compared to Sean Spicer I don't
know what the what the frame of
reference is and a source said to CNN
POTUS is very unhappy Sarah gave the
stormy Daniel storyline steroids
yesterday and then we got a follow-up
statement from stormy Daniels's attorney
who said yeah and he won the popular
vote to president Trump hasn't won
anything related to Miz Clifford that
stormy Daniels real name first of all it
doesn't appear as if he was even a party
to the arbitration miss Sanders is
referring to how can you win something
you're not even a part of secondly
claiming that mr. Trump won at
arbitration when there has been no
hearing no notice to miss Clifford no
opportunity to get given to her to
respond and no decision on the merits is
completely bogus not a good day for
Sarah Huckabee Sanders and clearly not a
good day for the narrative that Trump
has no idea it's all super confusing
where is this story coming from we don't
get it and I've said before that I find
Sarah Huckabee Sanders to be she
transmits this visceral feeling of
grandiosity about herself she really
seems to relish sort of exerting control
over the press corps during these
briefings and I for one am glad that she
has finally now slipped up and might
experience the wrath of an unhappy
Donald Trump yeah yesterday you were
talking about who in the White House is
likely to be the next to go I didn't
name her Sarah Huckabee Sanders wasn't
on that list now after this gaffe I
think you have to put her on there
things can to make a 180 very very
quickly with Trump you can get on
Trump's bad side in an instant and that
is what it appears that Sarah Huckabee
Sanders did so what will be next I mean
listen ultimately I think we all realize
that there's going to have to be some
accounting for or explanation of the
entire stormy Daniels thing my
diction would be that without ever
admitting anything we will get some kind
of statement saying yeah we paid her off
because she was lying at a time when it
could have affected the campaign and we
wanted to get her out of the way without
ever admitting anything although it
becomes more and more difficult to
believe that with every passing day send
me your thoughts on this story I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show we'll be
back right after this the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com this program is mostly
supported by viewers and listeners of
the show through something called the
membership program and through our
patreon fundraising page and today's new
member of the day is brandon long car
brandon thank you for being a member I
also want to thank our sustaining member
of the day Clinton Lowe who has been
with us since August of 2011 and you can
join Brandon and Clinton at a 40%
discount right now if you use the coupon
code vote soon 18 at david pakman.com
slash membership we will soon be
announcing actually a pretty cool
initiative that will relate to sort of
the expansion of the show when it
relates to membership it relates to
patreon really throw a lot of very
exciting things but in the meantime
david pakman.com slash membership if you
want a free david pakman show
bumper-sticker available in either of
two colors black or white sign up for a
new yearly membership at david
pakman.com slash membership and then
just get in touch and tell me which
color bumper sticker you want and where
we should send it and we'll get that
right out to you I also invite you to
participate in the david pakman show
subreddit nearly 6,000 of our viewers
and listeners regularly discuss and
debate politics there a few interesting
discussions that I saw this morning when
I browse david pakman.com slash reddit
1 is a post arguing that the left
doesn't take anti-semitism seriously and
the post specifically relates to the
vile and toxic anti-semite Louis
Farrakhan Farrakhan I'm not even sure
how to pronounce his last name but big
picture I've talked about this issue
before I do think that there is a
problem on the left of not taking
anti-semitism seriously there's the idea
that Jews are doing great in the United
States and so even if there is any kind
of antipathy towards Jews we don't
really need to worry about it and it's a
very very easy way to minimize
anti-semitism and I generally do agree
with that so yes very interesting
discussion also from the David Pakman
show subreddit a poster says I honestly
enjoy
the David Pakman show but does anyone
else think he can be very condescending
to callers and guests and interestingly
just about everybody who responded the
depth of this said no I don't think
David is condescending to the guests I
think that David is very direct with
them if they're wasting time or if
they're not getting to a question or if
they're filibustering but you should
watch other shows if you think David is
condescending to guests
I I don't you know listen I'm not gonna
baby if you're choosing to call into a
show and make a political claim I'm not
gonna treat you like you're a kid if I
disagree with you I will tell you if I
believe that you're not defending your
assertion I will tell you and if I think
you're wasting my time I will also tell
you but it's not like people are victims
when they choose to call into the show
and make a point right I I don't know I
intend to disagree with sometimes we're
a little too respectful I would say I
argue the same thing when I allow
someone to go on for two minutes without
asking any questions and then eventually
I say listen you're killing me I got to
get the question from you it's it's my
television though I don't disagree but
it also is necessary we got to move the
show along right also from the David
Pakman show subreddit is there a way to
be pro-israel and not support Benjamin
Netanyahu yeah you just say I believe
Israel should exist and is a valuable
project and I am against Benjamin
Netanyahu I mean it's it's sort of
straightforward I think maybe the better
question or maybe the implicit question
here is is there a way without
supporting the current regime to still
be seen as a supporter of Israel and I
would argue it depends who you ask
because there are definitely extremist
right-wing elements who see anything
short of total support for Benjamin
Netanyahu as being against Israel yeah
and yeah I mean the answer is very clear
and resounding yes feel like you've been
doing it for a long time Pro anti
Benjamin Netanyahu please please and
thank you I appreciate that I wasn't
gonna pat myself on the back but if
you're gonna point out that's my
position I'll gladly accept it also from
the David Pakman show subreddit a very
interesting article about how the NRA
and its allies used jargon and semantics
to bully gun control supporters this is
very very true and one really good
example is that
because the ar-15 rifle has played a
role in so many mass shootings it's
become popular for the pro-gun right to
ask people who believe ar-15 should be
banned if they know what AR stands for
and many people will say yeah it stands
for assault rifle 15 which is wrong AR
stands for light Armalite the company
that made the first of that style right
I don't think this anymore yes that's
correct but it doesn't matter right I
mean the article is very good because it
points out that it doesn't matter
whether you know what AR stands for you
can still think that it should be a
weapon that is or isn't banned right and
it's a very very interesting article
that someone posted to our subreddit and
I encourage you to check it out and you
can participate in all of these great
discussions at david pakman.com slash
read it it's been a while since we had a
successful or I guess even attempted
murder of someone associated with Russia
under sketchy circumstances and by a
while I mean it's been a few months I
guess and the BBC is now reporting that
a nerve agent was used to try to kill a
former Russian spy and his daughter
sergey skripnikov
was sentenced to 13 years in Russian
prison for passing intelligence to some
British intelligence agents mi6 agents
from the UK in the UK and he was
eventually released by Moscow a few
years ago in 2010 in exchange for 10
Russian spies that had previously been
arrested by the FBI and Sergei scribble
and his daughter Yulia scribble were
found unconscious in the UK over the
weekend and they still remain in
critical condition as of just a few
hours ago the police officer who was the
first responder to the scene is also in
critical condition because the poison
used is very very deadly it's a nerve
agent which is so toxic that it can stop
the nervous system from working properly
or at all when it succeeds in killing
people it shuts down basic bodily
functions it often enters through the
nose or mouth but it can also go in
through the eyes or even be absorbed
through the skin and this is being
sort of a parallel incident to one
former Russian spy Alexander Litvinenko
was poisoned in London about 12 years
ago which was later determined to have
been approved by Vladimir Putin
personally and even the use of a nerve
agent like this tells us a lot because
if you're part of a gang if you're a
street criminal even mafias right they
don't typically have the means to make
nerve agents or even to get them usually
these nerve agents come from labs that
are often directly tied into
government's so immediately looking at
the background of Sergei scribble and
looking at the mechanism that was used
the focus becomes Russia here and Russia
also has a track record of using these
types of poisons they have a sort of
more general track record of
assassinating political enemies and
dissidents and Sergei scribble if you
look at his background there's some
pretty specific motive there right he
was providing information to British
intelligence and he was formerly
imprisoned previously imprisoned by
Russia and they're sort of very clear
motive here and every time this happens
there's this question of why now
right like why now given that this guy
has been out of prison for eight years
living in the UK why would Russia go
after him now that's also actually a
calling card of the Russians a long time
can go by you might think that maybe
they've forgotten or you know that they
don't forget and thus you're living
these entire eight years in fear and
then the poison shows up and this is
actually one of the more sinister cases
because usually Russia will only go
after the person themselves this time
his daughter also is in critical
condition and we don't know whether she
was sort of collateral damage because
these nerve agents are so deadly or
whether she was actually targeted by the
poisoner
but even if she was collateral damage
the fact that this was done with no
regard for possible collateral damage is
pretty gross and something else for the
Russia deniers here which there will no
doubt be many of in the current climate
Matt Tate
pointed out on Twitter that when you use
a poison like this you're kind of
deliberately you
so that it will be known who did it
right he tweeted anyone can fall off a
balcony or get shot in the street but
using isotopes that only occur in
specific reactors are VX that only a few
nation-states have labs that can make
isn't an accident its messaging you
betray us we kill you and your Western
handlers won't save you now the only
problem with that of course is that you
can make it so that anybody who wants to
frame someone who regularly uses this
stuff would be able to pretty easily do
it by using the poison that you're known
to use but again these are not exactly
poisons that you can get
over-the-counter or whatever the
equivalent would be to an
over-the-counter poison these are only
obtainable from a very limited number of
specific places that are able to produce
this stuff you use these poisons to send
a message right if they wanted this
whoever it was to look like a suicide
they could have sometimes that's still
suspicious like we've reported on
suspicious suicides that don't really
seem to be suicides but they could have
done it if they wanted it to look like a
simple murder maybe a robbery gone wrong
they could have made an attempt to do
that they didn't write they actually
chose to use the nerve the nerve gas and
by the way meanwhile are you as excited
as I am for World Cup soccer action in
Russia starting in just a few months
I've heard about that
I actually I mean I it's disgusting it's
disgusting that the World Cup is
actually going to be in Russia a country
that not only has meddled in our
elections and has tried to circumvent
and and as sort of a impact destabilize
democracy in the United States so many
times but even just the corruption to
get the World Cup I mean it is all so
disgusting and if it weren't for the
fact that I love World Cup soccer I
would be boycotting the yeah hire thing
and I really hope that you don't attend
because it's really hard to host the
David Pakman show you're a seasoned yes
and you have 50 stab wounds in your back
so listen I was recently talking to
former producer Lewis how much time do I
have not not that much I'll tell this
very quickly I was talking to a former
producer Louis and he has a plan in late
summer to go to st. Petersburg because
you can enter if you enter from like one
of the Scandinavian countries you can
get in for three days without needing a
visa that you would normally need I
think to go from the US and he said you
should come and meet up and I know that
North Korea I would not want to go to
even though I would find it fascinating
just because of the coverage from the
program I'd be worried that I'd be on
some list right I kind of think I'd be
worried about the same thing in Russia
at this point I really do and I don't
know if that's that's irrational but I
would hesitate to fly to Russia at this
point or to go in if something happened
to you it would be a major story but
that's true that's not really what
you're thinking about it no you know
what I know any publicity is good
publicity but ending up in some kind of
Russian prison is not really the
publicity that I'm looking for it could
be great for the show but we'd have to
find someone else to host the show that
would benefit from me ending up in a in
a Russian prison and speaking of which
not to go Russia overload out next is
the conclusion to our piece on what we
know so far about the Trump Russia story
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
welcome back to the David Pakman show
and now part two the conclusion to our
investigation into what we know so far
the knowns and unknowns of the Trump
Russia story the entire nearly half hour
piece will be on YouTube before you know
it
as far as collusion between the Trump
campaign and the Russian government like
I said very little is known right now
but we have to reserve most of our
judgements for when the facts come out
facts that at this point in time are in
the possession only of the Justice
Department and the congressional
intelligence committees here's one
instance of apparent collusion between
the Trump campaign and the Russian
government that we know about at least
an attempt at collusion June 9th of 2016
Donald Trump jr. Jared Kushner and Paul
Manafort literally the head of the
campaign met with a Kremlin connected
Russian lawyer for the purpose of
receiving dirt on Hillary Clinton before
the meeting Trump jr. was informed via
email that this dirt was part of a
Kremlin plot to help Donald Trump less
than a week earlier Trump jr. received
an email from an intermediary
representing a senior Russian government
official and Trump jr. knew he was
talking to someone representing the
Russian government the email to Trump
jr. said in part quote this would
incriminate Hillary and her dealings
with Russia and would be very useful to
your father this is obviously very
high-level and sensitive information but
as part of Russia and its government
support for mr. Trump Donald Trump's jr.
response was if it's what you say I love
it especially later in the summer the
intermediary wrote back to set up Trump
juniors meeting with a Russian attorney
the Russian attorney Natalya vessel
Mnet's kaya is well known for her work
on behalf of the Russian government to
advocate for the lifting of US sanctions
on Russia the Trump team and the Russian
lawyer did not just sit around talking
about the weather that day and long
after the fact Donald Trump jr. was
caught lying about the meeting not only
is this attempted collusion with the
Russian
but it might violate federal law which
states a foreign national shall not
directly or indirectly make a
contribution or a donation of money or
another thing of value or expressly or
impliedly promised to make a
contribution or a donation in connection
with any federal state or local election
it shall be unlawful for a person to
solicit accept or receive a thing of
value from a foreign national and by the
way this is just totally secondary Steve
Bannon later said that the chances of
those Trump campaign officials not
introducing the representatives from
Russia to trump while they were in Trump
Tower are zero and when I say that this
was attempted collusion I'm not saying
for sure
that it was only an attempt but I'm
saying it was at minimum an attempt the
Trump team could have been very
successful in colluding with Russia that
day but all we know for certain is that
there was an attempt and you can write
this off as no big deal but 90% of what
matters in this particular situation is
intent so let's talk about people
associated with the Trump campaign you
have to be naive to dismiss what we know
about the president's associates the
people that he and his campaign chose to
become involved with and their
connections to Russia other criminal
histories in some cases their blatant
desperate attempts to lie about and
cover up their dealings with the
Russians both during and after the
campaign Michael Flynn by the time he
was hired as a top adviser to the Trump
campaign was already known for his close
ties to the Russian government and had
been criticized for it by people from
all over the political spectrum when
illegally lied to the US government
about money he had received from the
Russian government Flynn spoke to
Russian ambassador kis lyac several
times during the Trump transition and
lied about it
one of those calls was on the same day
the Obama administration announced
sanctions on Russia and Flynn was forced
to basically admit that US sanctions
were discussed during the call Jared
Kushner during the Trump transition
discussed with russian ambassador kiss
lyac the possibility of using a Russian
consulate to set up a secret and secure
communications channel between the Trump
team and the Kremlin in order to hide
their conversations from American
intelligence this was at a meeting
between Kushner and kis lyac at the
beginning of December of 2016 at Trump
Tower Jared Kushner has also lied to the
US government about meetings he had with
Russians Trump campaign manager Paul
Manafort has a long history of both
criminal activity and loyalty to Russia
from oh six - oh nine he was paid ten
million dollars a year by Putin oligarch
Oleg Deripaska - secretly helped
influence politics media and business in
the US and Europe to benefit Russia and
for nearly a decade manna fort was paid
to manipulate Ukrainian politics to
benefit Russia which involved receiving
laundered Ukrainian tax dollars stolen
by pro-russian politicians in Ukraine
Manafort currently faces federal charges
in the u.s. including conspiracy against
the United States money laundering not
registering as a foreign agent and lying
to the FBI because of intercepted
communications and payments from Russia
during the Trump transition mana Ford
has been under investigation for the
past year by several US intelligence and
law enforcement agencies and was the
subject of FBI wiretaps before during
and after the 2016 election two weeks
before the Republican National
Convention mana Ford offered private
briefings on the election to Putin
oligarch Oleg Deripaska mana fort said
in the email if he needs private
briefings we can accommodate and again
this is another example of what we have
to wait and find out about before we go
dismissing these emails are among tens
of thousands of communications and
documents that the FBI has that the
public does not but man afford is a
confirmed person of interest in the do
J's Trump Russia investigation Trump
campaign advisor Michael Caputo had
previously worked on a Russian
propaganda campaign in the u.s. to
improve Russia's image among Americans
Trump campaign adviser Jeff Sessions had
to recuse himself from his own Trump
Russia investigation after it was
discovered that he lied about meetings
he had with Russia's ambassador to the
US Trump campaign advisor Carter Paige
has a long history with the Russian
government and is also under FBI
investigation and he's known among his
peers as an outspoken critic of u.s.
foreign policy and a strong Putin
sympathizer Paige has been known for
making public comments in Russia
criticizing the US and praising Putin a
US diplomat to Russia who knew Paige
said that he has always been a brazen
apologist for anything Moscow did from
Oh for 207 he worked in Moscow as a
banker and as a consultant to an energy
company owned by the Russian government
and in 2013 he helped the Russian spies
in New York City gather information
about sanctions and energy plans in July
of 2016 during the election Paige went
to Moscow to meet with Russian officials
and the Trump campaign including Jeff
Sessions were aware of this trip before
and after it took place for the
year-and-a-half that followed Paige in
the Trump campaign lied saying the
meeting never happened including Jeff
sessions who lied about it to the US
Senate also in July of 2016 Paige met
with Russian ambassador Sergey kis lyac
and lied about that as well Trump
campaign advisor Sam Nunn Berg has
confirmed that Trump campaign advisor
Carter page was colluding with the
Russian government and he believes that
the Justice Department has russia
evidence against trump specifically
george papadapolis was a trump campaign
advisor who one campaign official said
interacted with the Trump campaign
constantly in March of 2016
Trump identified Papadopoulos as a
campaign adviser and said he's an
excellent guy Papadopoulos stayed
influential throughout the election and
was even responsible for setting up
meetings for Donald Trump with world
leaders in April of 2016
Papadopoulos had a meeting with the
Kremlin middleman who told Papadopoulos
that the Russian government had dirt on
Hillary Clinton including thousands of
emails in January of 2017 Papadopoulos
lied to the FBI about his meetings with
Russians and then immediately tried to
delete all of his emails he had with
Russians he since pled guilty to lying
to the FBI and is now cooperating with
Robert Muller's investigation at the
very very least the Trump campaign was
filled with criminals people tied up in
Russian interests and people who were
constantly having meetings with the
Russians and lying about it all the time
in January of this year a member of the
House Intelligence Committee z-- Trump
Russia investigation said that members
of the Trump administration committed
crimes during the 2016 campaign in
February of this year another member of
that committee said that they have quote
an abundance of evidence that there was
Trump Russia collusion during the
campaign and as far as the Department of
Justice's investigation you might be
saying oh the investigations corrupt the
FBI and Muller occur upped what about
the new Ness memo the Nunez memo to
trump didn't change anything it didn't
prove that the Steele dossier was an
important part of the FISA applications
against Carter page never mind the fact
that more and more of the dossier has
been proven to be true the new Ness memo
made a lot of other unproven assertions
Nunez didn't even see the documents he
wrote about in the memo there's nothing
that proves the FBI acted improperly at
any point the FBI said the memo was
bogus and the Democratic memo refuted
every single thing in the new Ness memo
which essentially gets us back to square
one in terms of knowing who to believe
the point of all this some of what I've
discussed here is evidence of collusion
or at least facts that strongly support
the notion that there was collusion and
some of it is circumstantial but
important to keep in mind for the time
being but what the knee-jerk Trump
Russia deniers are demanding as further
evidence of collusion would only come
out in court proceedings which have not
yet happened most of these conversations
about whether or not there was collusion
simply need to be put on hold until the
investigation is over another thing to
keep in mind is that Trump himself did
not necessarily need to be personally
involved with Russian actors or even
need to be involved with conversation
with staffers about coordinating with
Russia Ford there to have been collusion
between the Trump campaign and Russia if
you're a member of the Trump campaign
and you're coordinating with Russia to
get dirt on Hillary or to promise things
to the Kremlin in exchange for election
interference most likely the last thing
you're going to do is keep trouble
himself updated for a number of reasons
mostly because it wouldn't be necessary
and it would be sort of stupid to
legally implicate your candidate and the
soon-to-be President Trump Russia
collusion is not defined by Trump
himself plotting participating in or
even having knowledge of the collusion
and setting this burden of proof is
unnecessary and it's often done so
disingenuously Trump has proven to
merely be a figurehead when it comes to
policy and when it comes to rhetoric
he's not a real thinker or a mover why
wouldn't the exact same circumstances
apply to collusion
I'm not even denying that the potential
collusion could have been very
low-budget and improvisational I've
never claimed that this was all part of
some grand scheme that started 20 years
ago where the Kremlin has been planning
for decades to install Donald Trump to
serve their interests I'm not even
saying that if there was collusion the
Kremlin had to have been plotting as far
back as even 2014 that's probably not
what would have happened that's the
caricature of what collusion would look
like that's the straw man but you have
to ask yourself why would Russia go to
such lengths to help a candidate that
would do nothing for them the Russian
government would not do all of this
unless they felt certain that it would
be in Russia's interest and why does
Trump feel so obligated to stay loyal to
the Russians when it comes to Russia
Trump has constantly praised Putin
refused to implement US sanctions on
Russia refused to admit the obvious fact
that Russia infiltrated the American
electoral process the list goes on what
we know is that Russia wanted to tip the
election in trumps favor
we know that the Trump campaign was
aware of at least that as early as June
of 2016 and many Trump campaign
so shi'ites had private meetings with
Russian officials or people tied to the
Kremlin which they lied about and we
only know about the meetings that have
so far been uncovered that's what we
know what we don't know is pretty much
everything that's the key point here we
know all of this and it's all very shady
but in the bigger picture we still know
almost nothing only the people
participating in the investigations know
anything even if we ignore the multiple
congressmen involved with the house
investigation who came out and said
we've seen evidence of crimes and
collusion even if we ignore the ties
between Russia and the Trump team
members and all of the lies and all of
the indictments we have to acknowledge
that we are currently only in the middle
of this saga and no one knows what will
happen because basically nothing much
has even had the chance to happen yet
the Trump White House and Trump
supporters and other Trump Russia
deniers say oh well we don't have
anything something would have happened
by now so Trump Russia is nothing other
than hysteria it's not true
this is meant to be an extremely slow
process it has to be in order to be
effective investigations like these
often take years and the people
conducting these investigations are
intentionally and carefully keeping the
details of what they're learning under
wraps we're just going to have to wait
to find out but in the meantime yes we
should not make hasty accusations
regarding specific circumstances and
situations but it would also make
absolutely no rational sense to assume
that there's nothing to the story given
what we already know and given that the
investigations have not yet even had the
opportunity to tell us what actually
happened
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
remember in high school yearbooks all of
those superlatives most likely to
succeed or most likely to do who knows
what end up in prison I don't remember
what they were in my high school there's
sort of analogies within the trump
cabinet right the most corrupt the most
morally reprehensible the most self
aggrandizing whatever for most
incompetent I still go back to Betsy
DeVos who was just completely and
totally out of her league during her
confirmation hearings really an
embarrassment to the country someone who
has no business whatsoever being
Secretary of Education Betsy DeVos
recently went to parkland Florida the
site of the recent mass school shooting
that left 17 dead as most of you know
lied about what she did there at least
exaggerated and then walked out of her
own press conference when the question
started to get a little bit tough the
the completely abortive visit to
parkland Florida started with a visit to
the school itself Marjorie
Stoneham Douglass High School student
journalists immediately started tweeting
that Betsy DeVos was not answering their
questions they wanted to talk to her it
was a school visit and she's the
Secretary of Education makes sense that
they would talk to her and here's where
it starts to sort of get a little weird
DeVos said to reporters adult reporters
that she toured the school with the
student journalists it appears that
that's sort of like the most charitable
charitable possible interpretation of
how it went she reportedly was seen by a
couple of students who took pictures of
her but by all accounts saying that she
toured the school with the student
journalists as an exaggeration she then
decided to hold a press conference now
to understand this next part recall her
totally nugatory confirmation hearings I
like that word she said she'd be up for
arming teachers in case they maybe need
to protect the students from a grizzly
bear attack instant classic right
instant viral video so at the press
conference students understandably
wanted to ask her about arming teachers
totally obvious totally expected you've
got the Secretary of Education in a
school after a mass shooting when both
she and the president that she works for
serves that the pleasure of have said we
want to look at arming
teachers there are going to be questions
about arming teachers she didn't like it
she ended up just walking away from her
podium effectively ending her own press
conference we've got a little bit of
video the audio from it is not not the
best but let's take a look Thank You
secretary Thank You secretary I love
that totally trigger which of trumps
people aren't clowns like can somebody
give me the list and I want to go back
to what I said at the start of the
segment can anyone email me or tweet me
if you can think of another Trump
administration official that is less
qualified to perform their job in the
administration than Betsy DeVos please
get in touch with me and if they could
find someone to even somewhat appear
competent in some of these positions
it's almost like they don't care and I
actually think that's the saddest part
of it that I don't think they do care
they just want to appoint there France
I'd like to nominate ben Carson
Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development to do what I also Rick Perry
Oh Secretary of Energy most incompetent
you know Rick Perry is at least from a
state that I don't know has both oil and
a big sort of like solar and and wind
say I'm really struggling here yeah I
know that they're not particularly
competent but I still even think that
Betsy DeVos is less qualified for the
position than ben Carson merely because
I think Ben Carson is generally more
intelligent and could sort of at least
learn by doing in a way that Betsy DeVos
seems totally unable to do but hey you
know what I'm willing to have my mind
changed who is less qualified and less
competent than Betsy DeVos and Trump's
cabinet for years I have been trying to
debunk this myth that people get more
conservative as they get older and I've
probably had more than a dozen guests
mostly conservatives but also liberals
who say as people age they become more
conservative in their
beliefs and people get confused because
if you do a survey at any given time and
sort the results by age brackets you
will see that the older groups have more
conservative political beliefs
so sometimes we see that and we say well
if the older you are the more
conservative your political beliefs the
younger you are the more liberal your
political beliefs it might stand to
reason that you become more conservative
as you get older and I've always
rejected this my thought has been that
because Society overall has been moving
to the left for many generations at any
given time if you do a survey the oldest
generations are going to be more
conservative and the younger generations
are going to be more liberal but I
believe that actually an individual's
politics remain pretty stable during
their lives and we now have a study that
confirms this because there's a new Pew
Research study which looked at the
voting preferences of four groups which
we're gonna put up on the screen for you
Millennials Generation X baby boomers
and the Silent Generation the Silent
Generation is people born from about the
mid 1920s to the mid 1940s and what
you'll see if you look at the graph and
I'll describe it to people who are
listening on the radio or listening to
the podcast is that each of the that by
and large the members of these four
different generations have been voting
in the exact same way over the last
twenty four years now Millennials are
still so young that we don't have voting
data for them for as long a lot of them
have only been voting since 2006 or even
later but as you can see here when you
look at this image the numbers are
really pretty steady and congressional
election voting over time each
generation is not getting more
conservative and some of these if you
actually want to really get into the
details of the numbers you'll notice
might even be getting more liberal as
they get older this pretty much makes
sense intuitively because after being I
don't know I would say once you're a few
years out of college like college is a
time where it's more common to undergo a
more radical shift in beliefs or for
people who don't go to college I would
still say even during the typical
college age years is when more people
will change their political beliefs but
once you're
24 25 26 political views aren't going to
change drastically except in extenuating
or unique circumstances if you happen to
be older than that maybe at the time of
something like the Great Depression or
9/11 or some incredibly monumental event
but by and large people's political
beliefs aren't going to change that much
so the real question that we should all
have looking at this data is if each
subsequent generation is further and
further to the left why aren't our
elected officials more and more to the
left and that has to do with a few
different issues all of which we've
talked about gerrymandering by
Republicans number one most importantly
though voter turnout voter turnout is
pathetic in the United States and it is
particularly bad among the younger
generations so what you have when you
have older generations being both more
conservative but also voting more is
that you have an electorate that skews
right despite the fact that the people
of the country are moving more and more
to the left and the solution is really
simple the good news I have for you is
that the solution isn't mind-blowing if
more young people voted then our elected
officials would be more in line with the
politics of the country overall meaning
more to the left
Republicans know this that's why they
don't want voting hours on campuses they
don't want on-campus voter registration
drives they oppose any measures that
would stimulate young voters to vote
because they know that the right does
better when the electorate is older at
any given time that's all the time I've
got today I had a great voicemail to
play for you but it's gonna have to wait
we've got a great bonus show today as
well we will speak to you that
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]